Do you consider shooting a martial art
and how has your firearms training been
like or unlike martial arts training?
Well,
shooting is absolutely a martial art.
Yeah.
I mean maybe not the way people pictures
of martial arts nowadays be. Oh,
because when you picture a
martial art people picture,
you know a guy with a Guiana. Yeah,
doing karate. That's, that's right.
That's the generic picture. To me
that's not, that's not martial arts.
Actually to me martial
arts is the art of war.
The Art of the individual
warrior skills that it takes.
And firearms are absolutely a martial art
because it's something that you train.
It's something that you get good at.
It's something that you need
to maintain your skill at.
And it is absolutely a martial art.
And to me
it's another piece of the puzzle.
It's another thing that you should,
you need to know how to do.
And just like tactics that go along with
shooting are an important part of being
a warrior.
You need know how to shoot in.
The training is very similar in my mind
to martial arts training in that it
takes, you know, repetition.
You have to know what the basics are
and you have to repeat those basics and
then you get more advanced and it's,
it's about movement and getting
efficient with your movement.
And then you want to train it very
similar to the way that you train mixed
martial arts or martial arts in
general. And that is, you know,
you're going to have different frat levels
and how you get to deal with them and
you want to deal with your
weak side, you know, you can,
you shoot with your off hand in
various environments in the low light,
in the dark, in the rain, in
the, you want to mix it up.
So you're used to all of it. You want
to be used to people at close range,
you want to be used to
people at a further range.
And then once you get all
those mechanical skills down,
then you want to train your
mind around this thing.
You want to train your mind around this
skill so that your mind knows how to
utilize this skill when things are
unexpected and when there's chaos and when
there's mayhem going on.
And that's,
that's one of the things that I really
like about simunition training or paint
ball training or laser tag
training is it allows you,
it allows you to have somebody
else shoot back at you,
which is just like,
you know,
just like rolling in Jujitsu or sparring
more Thai or sparring MMA is you have
to react to the person. It's
no longer just a Kata, right?
It's no longer just shooting paper targets
that don't shoot back and don't move.
So you, so I love to take it. Once you've
got the skills down and then you learn,
you've got the fundamentals down,
then you take the advanced fundamentals
and then you begin to train to simulate
combat. And this is oc
tell Ya, I had these, um,
I got these laser tag guns for my son
and I just got two of them at first.
But that escalated very quickly
because they were awesome.
There are these little nerf laser tag
guns and you could shoot each other at,
I dunno, maybe a hundred meters,
which is a pretty good shot,
is like a pistol.
And so when I got these,
and as soon as I got two of them
and I realized how good they were,
I bought two more so I could go against
my son and his friends and they could go
against each other.
And I taught my son like all the basic
military maneuvers that he would need to
know. And this is when he
was maybe eight years old and
he would play this game
all the time, you know, in.
So I taught him out of covering move,
I taught them how to
get elevated positions.
I taught him how to do individual movement
techniques where you don't show your
face at the same spot,
like twice in a row.
Every time you get up you
move a little bit. And he,
he realized that that's how you win in
these little games and they're real.
Those are the real tactics.
And so I had a speaking,
speaking of speaking of the Marine Corps,
I had a friend that,
uh,
was,
was came over to the
house one time and he was,
you know,
a marine and
we got in the conversation
and all of a sudden, you know,
my son comes out with the laser tag
guns and my son's like, oh, you know,
do you want to go? And the guy's like,
you know, yeah, of course, let's do it.
So my son looks at him
and says, indoor, outdoor.
And you all of a sudden you could see
there was something going on and the guy
goes outdoor,
outdoor.
So my son that you press the button
on the thing and it counts down for 10
seconds and then it's on.
So, so you go find cover or
something like that. So yeah,
so 10 seconds, my son hits the
thing, my son takes off out the door.
So I'm watching the guy to guy,
this guy is doomed because you know,
you're going against the training.
So the guy comes out and,
and it's dark, right?
But the guy comes out of the door and I'm
watching him and he's kind of crouched
a little bit and all of a sudden his gun,
because it all is in this one system,
it's all takes place inside the gun.
You don't wear a helmet,
you don't wear anything. You actually
are shooting the other person's gun. Oh.
And when it shot, when you,
when he gets shot, he goes,
existed does and shakes
and a red light flashes.
So he walks out and sure enough,
my son had run around the block at an
elevated position and as soon as he came
walking out, my son sort of drilling
him and the guy's like, he freezes.
It's interesting that he freezes.
He doesn't even think to myself, oh,
I'll take cover.
No,
he just froze and got drilled and then
as soon as it's easy standing there,
he's kind of looking around,
looking around, looking around.
Finally he sees my son, he starts to
point the weapon up towards my son.
My son just disappears.
And then the guys,
the guy starts kind of walking over in
that direction. And then 15 seconds later,
my son pops up on his flank and drills
them again from behind another fence in a
hole in the wall. And anyways, he ends
up killing them. And then the guys, okay,
let's go again. And my son beat
him like three times in a row.
And it's because he had the basic,
the basic skills,
basic infantry men skills is what it was,
you know, he would shoot and then move.
And that's what it boils down to.
So that kind of thing is,
is very important in as
far as being a martial art.
And you should train, you know,
that's another thing, you know,
I said this to Sam Harris when I
was on his podcast, you know? Yeah.
Maybe there's no chance
because you live in, uh,
in the bubble and you live in a great
neighborhood and you're well protected.
You have alarm system in
your house and all that.
And maybe you're never gonna have a
problem. And that's great. I mean,
there's always a chance.
I would never believe that.
You're never gonna have a problem,
but there's always a chance that
somebody is going to crunch,
that's evil's going to enter your world
and you want to be ready for that.
Now, if that makes me
sound paranoid, okay,
let's just say you're not paranoid
and you don't think it's ever going to
happen,
but it is still highly valuable to train
in these situations because they make
you a better person. They make you
sharper, they make you smarter,
they make you more prepared.
If something does happen,
it's just good to know this stuff
and it makes you a better person,
more reliable. It's a
real skill set. You know,
I always was kind of bummed out about
basketball or football or baseball because
those are the, there. There are
life skills involved in Amman.
I don't wanna say that, but the
skill itself of throwing a baseball,
of shooting a basketball,
of throwing a football is not as
valuable as a skill as number one.
A martial artist, you know, moy,
Thai boxing, wrestling, Jujitsu,
because those are real applicable,
applicable to life. 100%
and this is the same thing
with shooting a gun. I mean,
that is a real applicable skill that
you may need at some point in your life,
and you should have it,
you know?